[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola buenas tardes bien tenemos una
frase ahí atrás que todos hemos
escuchado que es los viajes ilustran
probablemente es una de las frases más
populares y más conocidas relacionadas a
los viajes yo lo uso mucho todas las los
hemos usado me acuerdo pero no recuerdo
porque yo viví esa época pero me acuerdo
cuando empecé a estudiar sobre el
turismo
acerca del gran tour hace más o menos
varios siglos los jóvenes burgueses
viajaban hacia una ruta por europa que
le llamaban 'el grande' y era una ruta
que ellos hacían para educarse para
recorrer europa más o menos en un año el
tiempo dependía de cada uno de ellos
pero podían ver con sus propios ojos lo
que antes solamente se podía ver en
libros no podías leer pero a través de
ese viaje te podías ilustrar
esa frase que se repite y se repite toma
un nuevo significado hoy en día y es que
hoy por hoy la tecnología que nos
permite y esto es una maravilla a mí me
encanta esto que nos permite viajar a
una velocidad que antes era inimaginable
ahora podemos tomar un avión y estar en
otro continente en cuestión de horas
tenemos en internet la maravilla del
internet que nos mantiene conectados o
desconectados las redes sociales que nos
inspiran a viajar para que al mismo
tiempo nos dan esa necesidad y a veces
esta ansiedad de querer compartir
nuestras travesías a veces parece que sí
que si no lo subimos a instagram el
viaje nunca lo hicimos y es muy curioso
porque ahora con los viajes es esta
cuestión de si la tecnología nos ayuda a
estar más presentes y conscientes de los
lugares que visitamos o por el contrario
nos da el lujo o la desgracia de que
podamos atravesar el mundo sin tener la
mínima conciencia del lugar que estamos
pisando
es por eso que probablemente esta frase
habrá que replantear la y yo la pongo a
modo de pregunta hoy por hoy los viajes
ilustran es decir hoy por hoy en el
siglo 21 en el año 2019 los viajes
ilustran el solo hecho de salir de tu
casa de tomar un avión un autobús un
coche de cruzar el mundo o ir a otro
continente otro país otra ciudad ya está
en el hacer actuar dicho que lo que
vamos a hacer es regresar a casa
transformados es decir vamos a regresar
siendo más honestos
más respetuosos más tolerantes con
nuestras ideas taladradas
viajamos para ilustrarnos o nosotros
viajamos para ilustrar nuestras redes
sociales
por eso me hago esta pregunta que
probablemente a través de esta pregunta
nos lleve un camino para responder esa
pregunta si los viajes hoy por hoy nos
ilustran y es es viajar lo mismo que
irnos de vacaciones
esto es una idea que yo estaba manejando
desde hace años llevo más o menos 10
años viajando con mi blog alan por el
mundo un poco más viajando y grabando
los y tengo la oportunidad de viajar por
el planeta grabar mis contenidos y
compartirlos en youtube en mis redes
sociales en mi canal vivo en mi página
de internet y con la esperanza de que la
gente que me ve se inspire y se inspiren
que en algún momento de sus vidas
decidan replicar parcial o totalmente
mis travesías o que solamente se
inspiren inicien sus propias aventuras
para mucha gente y para ojos de muchos
tengo lo que algunos dicen el mejor
trabajo del mundo
pero yo creo fielmente que cualquier
persona que ama lo que hace tiene el
mejor trabajo del mundo pero esa sería
otra plática
ahí estoy yo
y ese es mi trabajo generar contenido
alrededor de los viajes y me ha
replanteado muchísimas cosas acerca de
por qué viaje llevo todos estos años
viajando digo por qué porque estoy
viajando porque cuál es la necesidad que
tengo para viajar y cuál es el mensaje
que yo le doy a la gente que me sigue
porque ahora he visto en esta más de una
década viajando como se han ido
transformando los viajes y cómo me
encontrado ahora sitios en donde la
gente se forma horas literal horas para
tomarse una fotografía o la fotografía
para postear en instagram es muy curioso
porque probablemente ustedes y yo
descubrimos los viajes a través de lo
que es la industria turística es decir
puedes acercarte a una agencia de viajes
llegas te van a ofrecer un abanico de
destinos casi siempre los mismos una
ruta que puedes replicar
y va ser replicada por miles o hasta
millones de personas y el paquete va a
estar más o menos armado esa es la
industria turística y en ningún momento
me gustaría señalar que esto es malo al
contrario la industria turística da
muchísimos empleos tampoco en el
concepto de hablar sobre viajar o
vacacionar no es mi intención decir que
una cosa es mejor que la otra
simplemente entender que ambas tienen
objetivos o motivaciones diferentes por
lo tanto cada uno de nosotros al
entender esto podemos acomodarlo en
nuestra vida según nuestras prioridades
el turismo moderno nació hace un par de
siglos cuando los burgueses les
empezaron a sobrar dos cosas tiempo y
dinero y entonces empezaron a viajar
como diversión por ocio pero la realidad
es que nosotros empezamos a viajar
muchísimo antes que eso los seres
humanos somos nómadas es decir antes nos
movíamos por necesidad agarramos nuestra
casita nuestra familia nuestros
animalitos
y nos cambiábamos buscando pastos más
verdes nos movíamos viajábamos buscando
abundancia y un mejor lugar para vivir
la necesidad era el motor de nuestros
viajes por otro lado también había gente
muy valiente y curiosa que lo que quería
era saber que había más allá del otro
lado de la montaña más allá de esa selva
y emprendieron expediciones increíbles
en muchísimos casos o prácticamente en
todos a riesch ganando la vida para ver
qué había más allá y cruzaron mares ríos
selvas desiertos bosques para descubrir
el mundo como lo conocemos hoy en día
por lo tanto nosotros como seres humanos
empezamos a viajar por necesidad y por
curiosidad mucho antes que por diversión
o por ocio
y es aquí cuando me parece importante
señalar lo que es la diferencia entre
viajar y vacacionar que repito ninguna
es mejor que la otra simplemente en mi
punto de vista tienen lugares diferentes
las vacaciones para mí son ese momento
que todos nosotros necesitamos y quien
diga que no está mintiendo necesitamos
unas vacaciones para desconectarnos de
la rutina para desconectarnos del día a
día para hacer un 'break' un paréntesis
en nuestra vida normal por así decirlo
entonces podemos estar a gusto unas dos
semanas cuántas quieren en cancún en un
hotel todo incluido que nos atiendan y
estar divertidos y felices
para mí esos son las vacaciones y son
necesarias para cada ser humano viajar
para mí es otra cosa una de las cosas
que me sorprende es que cada vez más y
más personas tenemos la oportunidad de
viajar esto es una realidad usted lo
pueden ver cada vez hay más vuelos cada
vez hay más rutas cada vez hay más
hoteles cada vez más ciudades se
desarrollan enfocándose en los turistas
la diferencia entre vacacionar y viajar
no sería digna de mencionar sino resaltó
los regalos que cada una de estas cosas
nos dan por un lado creo que las
vacaciones llevan implícito el placer es
decir unas vacaciones deben ser
placenteras debemos estar a gusto en
nuestras vacaciones por otro lado el
viaje no siempre es placentero el viaje
no siempre es cómodo porque viajar si
viajamos por necesidad y por curiosidad
necesitamos esto salir de nuestra zona
de confort que es un concepto que todos
conocemos y hemos hablado mucho pero
para mí que me encanta viajar salir de
la zona de confort viajando es una de
las formas no sé si más placenteras pero
por lo menos más
antes lo curioso de la zona de confort
es que podemos estar allí todo el día es
como este círculo en el que estoy parado
toda nuestra vida podríamos estar dentro
de la zona de confort porque como no su
nombre lo dice está agusto estamos a
gusto aquí no pasa nada pero este es el
problema no pasa nada somos seres
humanos que buscamos satisfacción
queremos un propósito en la vida
queremos más y como un videojuego las
recompensas de la vida están fuera de la
zona de confort y hay que ir a por ellas
es salir y estas recompensas están en
muchísimos sentidos pueden ser
recompensas personales laborales
educativas de crecimiento incluso
espirituales la cosa es que la zona de
confort es maleable se va modificando
dependiendo de lo que hagamos y lo que
oye salir de la zona de confort mañana
probablemente es estar dentro de la zona
de confort por lo tanto requiere un
esfuerzo de cada uno de nosotros para
salir de ella e ir por las recompensas
que nos ofrece la vida por eso es que yo
me pregunto si los viajes hoy por hoy
me parece que hoy tenemos la oportunidad
de que el viaje no se ilustre por
disposición propia es decir no es en
automático vivimos en una época
maravillosa el planeta
en el que hoy nos podemos ir todos o
casi todos porque no sé si cabemos en el
avión pero nos vamos al aeropuerto de
monterrey
podemos tomar un avión que en 14 horas
nos dejan seúl corea
en 14 horas estamos en otro continente
en otro país en un idioma muy difícil de
hablar muy complicado de leer en un
mundo completamente distinto a nuestra
realidad sin embargo los tiempos
modernos nos ofrecen la oportunidad de
que aún estando en korea podemos dormir
en un hotel de cadena que se parece
muchos a los que tenemos aquí a dos
cuadras y podemos desayunar comer y
cenar en una franquicia norteamericana
y luego tomar un avión de regreso a casa
estuvimos en korea descubrimos lo que es
el kimchi el barbecue coreano los
palacios podemos hoy por hoy recorrer el
mundo para comer en el mismo lugar que
tenemos a dos cuadras de nuestra casa
pero tenemos otra oportunidad que si
queremos que los viajes nos ilustren si
queremos de verdad que los viajes nos
ilustren tenemos que ir con la
disposición de que los viajes nos
ilustren tenemos la enorme oportunidad
de ser la generación o las generaciones
que si subimos cosas a redes tomamos
fotos muy bonitas pero esas fotos son el
reflejo o la representación de un
momento en el que aprendimos en el que
crecimos en el que entendimos en el que
preguntamos el lugar donde estamos nos
interesamos por el lugar que estamos
visitando las fotos son la consecuencia
de nuestro viaje y no la razón del por
qué lo hacemos podemos ser la generación
o las generaciones que no huyen del
cliché sino que lo abrazan abrazamos en
cliché para tratar de entenderlo y así
reinterpretarlo todos hemos escuchado
que en el mundo ya no hay lugares para
descubrir
y probablemente nos metemos a instagram
vemos siempre los mismos y los mismos
lugares pero eso es una mentira hay
lugares allá afuera para descubrir y
aunque no existieran aunque nosotros no
seamos 'cristóbal colón' viajar es
descubrir nuestra propia versión del
mundo
para un europeo que sale por primera vez
de su continente y visita nuestro
continente está descubriendo américa
para él si nosotros pisamos una ciudad
por primera vez la estamos descubriendo
para nosotros no importa cuantas huellas
hay en la tierra que estamos pisando hay
que descubrir nuestra propia versión del
mundo somos tenemos la oportunidad de
ser la generación que se interesa por
los lugares que visita que recuerda que
podemos viajar por necesidad
y por curiosidad y podemos recordar eso
para motivar que nuestros viajes no se
eduquen y formen parte de nuestra
formación personal podemos ser la
generación que viaja con respeto con
tolerancia que se interesa por los
lugares que visita y que retoma el
viajar como antes lo hacían o lo
hacíamos los viajes se ilustran siempre
y cuando nosotros queramos ilustre y
para mí esa es la maravilla de viajar y
si nosotros agarramos nuestra mochila
nuestra nuestra maleta y salimos al
mundo que ahí nos está esperando un
mundo está allá afuera esperándonos a
todos y preguntamos y tenemos la
curiosidad y las ganas y le pedimos a
gritos al mundo que nos ilustre que nos
ayude a crecer y entendemos que los
viajes pueden formar parte de nuestra
formación personal de nuestro
crecimiento espiritual de nuestro
proceso como seres humanos les vamos a
dar el lugar que se merecen y entonces
cuando viajemos y pensemos en una tierra
que no nuestro
y si desplegamos una enorme sonrisa una
lágrima viendo un atardecer y regresemos
a casa transformados estoy seguro que
todos nosotros vamos a querer unas
placenteras y muy merecidas vacaciones
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]